[Music]
hello my name is Julian poo um I'm a
national master from St Louis Missouri
and today we're going to have an anti
opening principle uh discussion so a lot
of times you'll notice that pretty good
players violate the opening principles
and um um I'm going to explain sort of
when it's acceptable in my last few
lectures we've looked at a lot of
examples of you know one side following
the opening principles and the other
side you know not following the opening
principles and as a result the side that
doesn't get smashed um now we're going
to sort of take a look at the opposite
and um and why it works so um I played a
game against Evan Salmons in uh the K in
the Kentucky Masters or Kentucky
Championship some something like that he
played the move Pawn to D4 I played move
Pawn to G6 my opponent played Pawn to C4
I played uh Bishop G to G7 so far um oh
sorry he plays Pawn E4 so far everything
is so normal um black hasn't really
broken any opening principles here um he
has developed a piece that's following
the opening principles he hasn't really
controlled the center which is
definitely a negative and white has
definitely followed the opening
principles he has moved his pawns such
that they control the center and he's
ready to move pieces out uh to solidify
his control um of central squares I play
the move D6 again this move is pretty
normal no no principles have been
violated yet I am trying to control some
portion of the center and if my opponent
moves their pieces out maybe eventually
I'll play E5 or C5 and and strike in the
center um my opponent played the move
Knight to
C3 and again nothing nothing wrong with
this move um it develops a piece and to
control the center uh White obviously
still has some kind of Advantage I
played the move Pawn to C5 now this
again we so far everything is normal I
play Pawn of C5 which attacks the
Central Square so I am following the
opening
principles um my opponent played D5
trying to gain extra space and here um
there's an interesting option for black
which I really like playing and that is
Bishop captures Knight on C3 uh B
captures C3 now this does violate one of
the opening principles which opening
principle have I violated
it's the first question
yep yeah I moved the same piece twice a
mistake that was made in like the Opera
game that everybody you know everybody
likes to show this game as a chess
teacher and rightly so because black two
mistakes well sure after Bishop to G4 we
move our Bishop out and then takes we
played Bishop captures Knight so we
spent two moves to trade off for a piece
that only moved once so you may ask me
well what's the the difference between
that position and this
position um well first of all black has
gained something very Concrete in terms
of like a positional Advantage what
positional Advantage has black got in
exchange for his um in exchange for
wasting time
yes yeah the the double the double pawns
on C3 and C4 as bunzo was was grunting
to me um the other thing
is um okay I played a move here with
black the move Mo controls the center
it's a good move and that is Pawn to
E5 the reason why this is good uh so I
mean we we're putting a pawn the center
but also we are trying to lock the
position we've given away a bishop for a
knight and the reason why this is
acceptable the reason why it's
acceptable to waste time and the reason
why it's acceptable to give away our
Bishop for a knight is because the
position is more locked and closed
that's why we can do this if the
position were open like for instance
these these pawns were all exchanged
then white would probably be um close to
winning actually maybe not the D Pawn
because then white would have isolated
isolated pawns but if the E and F pawns
for instance were were traded then I'm
sure white would have a winning
Advantage but
because um uh but
because uh pawns have not been
traded um all eight pawns are on the
board for both sides uh and the play is
slower we can afford to waste time with
moves like Bishop C3 and technically
white doesn't have anything out yet um
so as somebody rightly asked well what
about the weak dark squares on the king
side you will notice that I am trying to
put all of my pawns on dark squares
because I have exchanged my dark Square
bishop and generally speaking um you
want to put your pawns on the color
opposite of the bishop that you have uh
um when you're playing against the
bishop pair okay um some comments I
don't particularly understand um okay so
my opponent played Bishop D3 which is a
really normal developing move or or
seems to be the case um this actually
isn't really the most dangerous move in
the position um I'd say the most
dangerous common move in this position
is the move Pawn to F4 the reason why F4
is dangerous is white aims to open the
center right I just told you a big
downside um of Black's position is if it
opens up then white has the two Bishops
and we've wasted a bunch of time um and
here after e takes F4 Bishop takes f
four um if I play the move Queen H4 with
black uh this is the main line um the
point of this move is we would like to
attack the king and the bishop and force
a reaction um almost everybody plays
this move Pawn to G3 which is super
weakening by the way this also violates
the opening principles we are moving Our
Queen out too early but it's done with a
very um specific reason um you have to
understand why these principles are the
way they are so the opening principles
are control the center develop your
pieces cast the negative principles are
don't make too many pawn moves don't
move the same piece twice and don't move
your major pieces out too early why are
these principles the way they are all of
those principles can be boiled down to
essentially one thing don't waste time
in the opening that is the point the um
the other uh principle about controlling
the center is about Square control you
want good squares for your pieces and
it's easier to do that if you have more
central control because from the center
you can go to the king side and the
queen side at least that's the general
logic um given by you know all the chess
uh Chess Masters in the past um Queen H4
does move the queen out too early but we
are attacking a major piece sort of in
if if white plays the move G3 well
that's not a move that develops a piece
and attacks Our Queen right that's just
another pawn move so Pawn to
G3 um uh doesn't really increase White's
development after Queen to E7 um
potentially we want to take this Pawn
actually we we don't which I'll talk
about in a second but we want to develop
these pieces but we also want to make
sure that this Bishop's Mobility has
been further limited so the bishop can't
go back this way anymore we put the pawn
on G3 this bishop really doesn't want to
go to G2 it wants to go to D3 where it
eventually can attack the king side um
on G2 it's okay it's not nothing special
and the way that black gets like a
playable position here is to do
something like Knight F6 Knight D7
Knight G4 whatever you put your squares
your your pieces on um on the dark
squares and you achieve some kind of
dark Square blockade at least that's
that's the idea when you play this
opening with black eventually you aim to
get some position that looks like this I
don't know if this is like a very
precise move order or not but we want to
put a knight on the E5 Square Castle um
and just claim that white can't break
through our position but this isn't the
best way for white to
play shockingly the best move for white
to play is Bishop to
G3 and then in response to Bishop G3 the
best move for black to play is Queen to
E7
why is Queen takes E4 a bad move this is
really
hard white to play what would you like
to do with white and
why somebody said develop which which is
funny just some random axium right
develop now so this this class is going
to be about concrete chest right why are
the opening principles the way they are
why was it okay to break the opening
principles with white and with black and
in the these cases right so you're going
to need need to give some very concrete
analysis to prove one thing or
another so the best move the best move
for white is
shocking which kind of indicates to you
what piece you should probably
move like it wouldn't be shocking if the
answer were like I go Knight E2 Bishop
B2 or whatever that wouldn't be
surprising is it King D2 yeah obviously
King D2
it got to be you're like what what is
King D2 all about Black is not in a
position to punish White's King
placement like let's be very clear this
is where your army is Right sleeping
back home D6 is
attacked and you might think oh I'll
just like defend it but then the big
idea of King to D2 is I play this move
Queen
E1 and D6 is um is attacked and if you
take well now your king is going to be
weakened this end game game with
constant pressure against the D6 Pawn
it's not super important that white is
down a pawn here because the pawn he's
down is this e e Pawn which he can use
to his Advantage by putting Rooks on the
open file White's development Advantage
here is really good and he can play for
an advantage um that's some like
computer analysis I think if you don't
look at this position with a computer
there's like a 0% chance you play Bishop
G3 because you're like oh I blunder my
Pawn you're not going to think uh yeah
King D2 that's good but if you um if you
know the position you understand the
reasoning behind the moves then then it
like kind of kind of makes sense um
there's also a funny move based off a
very similar reasoning um and that is if
you play the move A4 a lot of times in
these positions you want to meet the
move A4 with the move
A5 um but here if you play A4 A5 after
Pawn F4 takes
takes
um uh
Queen uh
Queen uh H4 Bishop G3
uh s right Queen E4 is very similar so
let's say you go Queen E7 which is what
you wanted to do anyway in the in the
previous line where we would try to get
the same like kind of light uh um dark
Square blockade white now has the move
Rook e A2 and then Rook E2 is going to
crush you in the center with E5 that
move looks really weird but it actually
has like a very um very clear point to
it which kind of follows the opening
principles right one of the opening
principles is to control the center um
you're like well don't move your major
pieces out too early you should ask why
why don't you move your major pieces out
too early it's because generally
speaking when beginners move their major
pieces out too early your opponent like
gains Time by attacking them that isn't
true in this case Rook A2 is really
strong I'm going Rook E2 you can't stop
me and then when E5 comes it's going to
um yeah it's going to wreak havoc in
Black's position um Okay so
uh which actually means in after A4 you
can't play the move A5 and for what it's
worth I think the best move here is this
move Queen H4 which is again funny
bringing the queen out too early um but
the reason for this is concretely we
want to play in the center with F5 and
after Knight F3 we can bring our Queen
back and um black is worse here I'm not
going to you know mince words black is
definitely worse in this kind of
position but it's the kind of position
that's like tense you can play for a
fight and even though we're down a lot
of developing moves the center is still
like
locked um and I think that's why like
white generally plays a move like e
takes F5 here you want to open the
center but it's going to be hard to
create inroads to Black's cane and if I
complete development then I'm probably
not worse um okay uh
yes I guess I don't
see why Queen H makes sense here
ah I mean you could have gone F5 here so
if you play F5 yeah s right that's that
is a really good question I should have
I should have brought this up so if you
play F5 here then white will take you
and if you take back then Queen H5 is a
big deal your king is now actually going
to be weak white is going to generate
play on that side of the board and
create some kind of initiative if you
play the move Queen H4 you're gaining a
Tempo on e4 after Bishop D3 F5 we now
can recapture with our Pawn on G6
whereas in the previous case we would
have had to recapture with our Bishop
which is not ideal because we give away
the E4 Square I'm very happy you asked
that question because I forgot so I
would not have thought to ask that
question again myself but yes we want to
capture with our pawn and queen H4
prevents Queen H5 what about
like I guess like Queen E7 first instead
of going well Queen E7 means that he
doesn't have to play Bishop D3 so he so
for instance um after Queen
E7 uh I might do something something
else um some more important developing
move um I'm not exactly sure I think uh
Queen E7 might even be like one of the
moves that's acceptable like you could
do this instead of Queen H4 and this is
like maybe not as good as Queen H4 but
like very similar in value um but queen
queen H4 is also a uh um a good idea a
queen E7 also seems fine um Breaking All
the Rules just equals Mo uh modern and
uh modern and nimit lson no uh well it's
a little more complic
they mean like the opening the modern
and the opening the like B3 that's what
they're talking about um I'm going to
show another game where I didn't play B3
uh if we have time and uh that game was
pretty complicated too okay so I played
E5 and the game went Bishop to
D3 I played the move Queen to E7 uh
bunzo style and here my opponent played
Pawn to
H4 okay what do you guys want to do with
black and why this may seem like a very
simple question question to you maybe it
isn't simple I don't
know somebody wrote stop
H5 so
how another person says kns nights
out so I let's try to combine those two
Commons together so that would imply
Knight F6 right because Knight F6 is the
only move that moves the Knight out and
stops H5 in theory Knight F6 is a really
bad move because in response to Knight
F6 your opponent might play Bishop to G5
and you get perap pinned um actually I
take that back if Bishop G5 you can go
H6 and nothing nothing bad really
happened but um okay uh something like
Bishop H6 could be annoying and um it
kind of hurts your your development
scheme here white is aiming to play H5
so we should play H5 ourselves right so
H5 just makes sense there's the SSP
right Steven stop Pawn Steven sees you
want to push your Pawn so Steven you
know will stop you from pushing your
Pawn it's a reference to one of my
friends Stephen Adams who has this rule
your opponent's good pawn move is your
good pawn move um I don't like general
rules you know in general which is funny
but uh this one this one has more
utility than most rules I would say
after H4 H5 we have stopped our opponent
from going to H5 and H5 was a big deal
if you did something random with black
like let's say Knight D7 then H5 this
relationship is really bad because I
decide when this file opens and your
Rook on h8 is unprotected and there's
not really a whole lot you can do about
that I can also decide not to take and
go H6 it's up to me um so I played H5
and then my opponent's next move is
objectively just a bad move here you
should play like F3 Knight E2 or Bishop
some some normal developing move um he
played the move Bishop G5 F6 and then
Bishop E3 in reality I was going to put
my Pawn on F6 by myself a part of
Black's development scheme which we're
about to see is you put this Pawn on F6
and you want to go Knight H6 Knight F7
and have like a a good fortification of
of the king side you want to have like a
very natural um development scheme that
isn't what that isn't what
happened um or sorry um he he should
have just played Bishop E3 and not
helped me play a move that I wanted to
play myself F6 also further solidifies
control of the center um so Bishop G5 is
just a bad move it waste a full Tempo
arguably two tempos so he played Bishop
E3 and then this next move nobody ever
sees coming oh wait actually no I didn't
play it play it now I played the move
Knight H6 which threatens Knight Knight
to G4 U potentially and also Knight to
F7 back he played the move Pawn F3 which
means that I will not be able to play
Knight to G4 and now it is black to play
what do you guys want to do with black
and
why
somebody wrote win me
too sometimes you can win sometimes you
can't it's not always up to
you you win some you lose
some break open the center I don't agree
you break open open the center you're
going to lose I told you the reason why
we are making so so many pawn moves and
not developing any of our pieces is
because the center is closed if you open
the center the center is not closed
anymore it's like those are
antonyms we don't know incorrect or
correct never
mind was going to say you don't know
isn't the answer but you actually don't
know so just
develop
maybe we won't have time to go over both
games
unclear
this next move is really hard In
fairness to you guys a bunch of random
moves have been suggested Knight A6 is a
random move I really don't like this
move
um because I don't really understand the
purpose like from A6 you want to go to
C7 I
guess the Knight on A6 is not going
forward it's overruled by all these
squares from C7 it can't go to B5 or E6
so I'm not really sure what the point is
of putting your knight on this
circuit somebody asks King
F7 King F7 is interesting Knight F7
continuing with the plan would be in
theme um I don't think that's what I did
but that's definitely in the spirit of
the position so Knight F7 would be a
pretty good move um and then you could
do what I did later but that's not what
I did at this exact moment in
time
although we can pretend I
did who doesn't love
pretending Knight A6 also PR prepares
castling Queen side uh Knight A6 to go
Bishop D7 and castles Queen side I
really don't like this idea because if
you put your pieces like this like let's
just pretend you go Knight A6 white goes
like Knight E2 or something then Bishop
D7 go Rook B1 one and then like castles
right um it is going to be really
difficult for you to longterm defend
your queen side if white starts playing
something like A4 and A5 it's just
really awkward on the side of the board
um you can't capture the pawn on A5 here
in fact in this type of position white
should just be winning your pieces are
horribly
misplaced I'll give you a hint the point
of this lecture is breaking all of the
opening
principles what's what's one of the
positive positive opening principles
let's name them
all not B6 there no B6 is bad I
agree Castle castling is one of the
opening principles but just like all the
other principles you follow them blindly
after castles they take your knight and
laugh at
you don't do
that are youve your queen
again uh no if I'm there's no point in
moving my queen again my my move has
purpose this move is really good because
it it has um has purpose all right let's
talk about the op principles again
because I love doing that if you develop
your pieces they're that's good because
your your pieces are out and like active
and doing something you want your pieces
to have jobs you don't want them to be
passive on the back rank doing nothing
right that's something you don't want to
do um so that's why one of the op
principles is to develop your pieces you
want to control the center because again
from the the center you control a lot of
territory it's going to be hard for your
opponent to put pieces in the center and
it's also going to be easier for you to
um put your pieces on natural squares
castling why do people Castle in
chess generally
speaking what is the point of
castling is
usually sides yeah exactly the point of
castling is to bring your king to safety
if it is the case the castling does not
make your king safer then why would you
Castle the utility in castling is to
make your king safer so violate
violating that rule doesn't make uh
doesn't make any uh if you blindly
follow this rule like okay let's say you
play Knight F7 white plays Knight D2 and
then you Castle here this would end up
being a horrible position for you
because even though technically speaking
we followed one of the opening
principles we didn't understand why that
principle was a principle that principle
isn't oh castling is the special thing
so I have to do it every game no I
Castle because I want main to be safe
after G4 takes H5 white has a has a
tremendous attack and um Black's
position could easily be collapsing
within the next few moves this could end
up being really really really bad I mean
G5 is probably the best that black can
do and something like Knight G3 takes
takes or H6 or
something uh White has a lot of play on
this side of the board that maybe he
doesn't doesn't deserve you can imagine
a knight ending up on the F5 square and
probably I didn't play the best for
white either um you can play G4 now or
later white can prepare that as much as
he likes so the move that I played oh
yeah bunzo I played the move King to
d8 and my opponent sort of gave me a
funny look after King d8 because I have
moved my queen my uh my king I've so so
let's let's tally I played Queen E7 King
d8 two major piece moves I've played 1 2
3 four five six pawn moves all right
it's move
11 so I've I've in theory VI violated
the opening principles um sorry what did
I say 1 two 3 four five six and then one
two so eight out of 11 moves I violated
some kind of opening principle but the
reason why I played King d8 is I want to
play King to C7 and my king is much
safer on this side of the board than
it's going to be on that side of the
board and the difference between doing
it this way and castling Queen side is I
can actually use my Rook as a Defender a
big idea for white like let's say you
try to use your your major pieces here
like Rook B1 for instance I go A5 You
Queen B3 I go Rook A6 a big idea for
white is to play on the B file but after
I put my king on C7 my Rook on A6 what
Square are you going to invade on B7 is
defended by my my Bishop my Rook defends
B6 um even if you manage to get your
knight to B5 in the span of time that it
takes takes you to do that I will
probably take all your pieces and even
if I don't I'll play Knight D7 and King
B8 this is the safest possible
construction for my king in the current
position this is why um King d8 is such
a good move um you want to be able to
defend with your pieces on the queen
side and also the point of developing
your pieces is such that they're active
right my Bishop cannot be any more
active than it is on its starting Square
you can't pick up that bishop and put it
anywhere on the board where you know
it's a from capture where it has more
legal moves you just can't do it right
um
E8 uh yeah sorry you can put on E8 but
C8 is is is pretty is pretty
good D7 D7 now D7 Cuts connection from
other pieces yeah I'm just saying oh
okay okay fine fine fine fair enough
this bishop is really useful both as an
attacker and a Defender so I don't need
to worry about that piece but I do need
to worry about is my king the point of
castling early and often is to bring
your king to safety and that's why I
played King d8 to try to go King to C7
okay my opponent played the move Knight
to E2 um I played King to C7 he played
Queen C2 I played the move Knight to F7
and then a in a
funny uh funnily enough my opponent kind
of agreed with the way I was played and
played the move King D2 himself he
decided yeah castling that way doesn't
make any sense because my pawns on H4
now maybe my opponent will go F5 one day
and take the pawn H4 obviously I can't
play F5 now he's going to take my Pawn
on F5 but eventually um the other thing
if if you Castle Queen side little what
does that really do that's different
from King D2 now in my opinion you
probably should just Castle Queen side
but King D2 is fine I played the move um
Knight to
D7
uh so the point of Knight D7 is to um
well I this is the one piece that hasn't
hasn't actually completed its
development it would be really nice on
the B6 Square where it's targeting C4 um
white plays this move Pawn to G4 he's
trying to claim he's taking advantage of
my Bishop on
C8
okay what would you guys like to do here
with black and
why I think most of the times that I've
shown this game I kind of glossed over
this decision without without making it
clear that there was a decision to be
had here but there is there is a
decision here to be
made
Target the B4 Pawn that's incorrect
because there's no B4
Pawn can't Target something if it's not
there I'm sorry which is why you should
lose your queen you lose your queen the
camp blunder
it why you play this way why you should
play
this no Pawn on B4 to Target I am so
sorry G4 dyslexia well what do you want
to do
then somebody says they're standing on
their head watching I approve You're
Breaking All the Rules just like I did
in this
game
normally one stands on their feet and
not their head but there are some
talented people out
there all right somebody says take the
G4 pawn and that is I think the correct
decision the the decision here more or
less is do you want to move your knight
first or do you want to take on G4 and
the answer is to take on G4 is just
objectively the best thing to do um why
why is that the best thing to do because
um well first of all you can kind of
logically figure out that this is going
to be the best thing to do because even
if I play Knight B6 white can choose to
achieve the same kind of structure um
like if white takes here and goes Knight
G3 um we're wasting a bunch of time
actually what I just said was false we
don't achieve the same structure I'm
sorry I'm I'm a little tired
um uh yeah so um this is a better
structure for white than the one he will
achieve in the game I played Pawn takes
G4 Pawn takes G4 Knight B6 which it does
come with Tempo if you let me take the
G4 Pawn I will take it I'm a greedy
bastard you give me something I'll take
it that's how it works um so he played
Rook G1 to defend his Pawn but the thing
is um this structure is worse for white
um and since this is a road to 2000
class and in theory it should be hard I
want to ask you why why is this
structure worse for white than um than
this structure fundamentally there's a
fundamental difference between these two
structures why is the one he achieved in
the game better for
black uh somebody says we have more
space but actually we have less space in
this position because White's pawns are
on G4 and H4
meaning they control more territory so
that is not the reason a weak
Pawn I don't think that any of the pawns
on the board are particularly weak are
weaker than they would I mean F3 and G4
maybe G4 is a little
weaker there's something very specific
and it has to do with the Kings being in
the
middle
less developed okay so the development
is actually kind of coming to a close
like both sides are going to be pretty
well developed in a second um actually
I'll just tell you in the game I played
Bishop D7 and now the opening phase is
over right in theory the opening is over
once the Rooks are connected both Rooks
are staring at each other my Keen is
safe all of my pieces have a purpose
black has played a successful opening um
white in this position has also in
theory played a successful opening
because all of his
pieces are are out now there is
something about this structure that is
bad for white and I want you to try to
figure out what is bad about White's
position the white kinge is kind of
close to being smothered we're we're
getting in the right
direction I
mean King on D2 isn't great in fact
there's there's a huge tactical
liability that's about to happen because
the K's on D2
bad white Bishop the bishop was both bad
in the previous position and in this
position in fact um White's bad light
squared Bishop is the only reason why
this variation is playable at all if
White had a good light Square Bishop
then you you'd be in
trouble that's your compensation for not
having the bishop here is the bishop on
D3 is not a very good
piece yeah okay we we got somewhere so
you you got the F5 uh break prep so
black has the ability to open the center
and white does not have the ability to
open the center and in response to F5
you do not have this F Pawn that can
recapture on e4 that is a huge
difference so if we go back to the
structure where um you Knight B6 after
gh5 takes Knight G3 if black plays the
move F5 in some position yeah it'll okay
in the current position we're
threatening F4 which wins a piece uh
first of all it's harder to achieve F5
because the knight's on G3 but second
let's pretend that you do achieve F5 and
then you don't like win a piece after F4
like I just go away when you take on e4
white can take back on e4 it's not clear
how you're breaking through the center
the reason why the king would be bad in
the center in any position is because
you can open the center Center and try
to attack The King The King being in the
center inherently isn't a bad thing the
reason why it's bad is because of
concrete tactics right chess is a
concrete game you're going to have to
have some very concrete reasoning why
something is good or bad after takes on
G4 takes Knight B6 G4 is attacked Rook
G1 Bishop D7 um my opponent played a
mistake here um and now should be losing
he played the move Bishop to F2 the
reason why he did that was because if
you play some random move okay A3 is not
a particularly good move but let's just
say you know make it for argument sake
after this move
F5 if you play the move um G takes G
takes e takes for instance it's now
black to play and
win what would you guys like to do here
with
black and
why although this is more like a
tactical question than a positional
question
Bishop F Bishop F5 uh is the right idea
but you have something better Bishop
well Bishop F5 Bishop F5 I'm not sure
what your so your tactic is Knight C4
right that's what you wanted to do to
attack the king and here you need
something after King
D3 what
pawn oh well you sacrific the piece
right so if you win two pawns for the
piece that's not going to be enough
yeah chat is chat is screaming the
answer they're all falling over each
other's chairs to just type in the right
answer poor chat no voice come to the St
Louis chess club then you can yell at me
in
person
oh scre think see E Yeah E4
so your idea of Bishop F5 distracting
the bishop is is good but E4 is better
because you're using a pawn to do so
after Bishop takes E4 now we can play
your knight C4 move so D2 is attacked E3
is attacked the only square that defends
both things is King D3 we have a pretty
good response to that it's black to play
what would you guys like to do with
black if you don't play the best move
zero
credit you have a lot of good moves a
lot of winning
moves you only credit for one of one of
them which is
looks like Checkmate Checkmate isn't
that sick is that very
pretty just like take a second right um
so I really like this idea so did my
opponent which is why he stopped
me um and yeah if you don't play King D3
I take your Bishop for free so I'm up
I'm up a
piece all right um my opponent didn't
let me do this so F5 is like a big deal
um he played the move Bishop to f two
which aims to so now if you play the
move F5 you know taking on on C4 isn't
isn't winning the bishop anymore so he
can just go away right so that was the
point of Bishop to F2 but the bishop was
doing something important on the E3
Square so what would you guys like to do
with
black
H6 nice yeah so the bishop was
controlling this H6 Square Knight H6
attacks the G5 Pawn um probably white
wasn't going to take but white had
support for the move Pawn to G5 if the
bishop were on E3 that isn't the case
anymore now my opponent still played
Pawn to G5 but we because we're
attacking um you know the pawn on G4 uh
but now um I
decided to take take and go Knight G4 um
I also calculated A variation which was
Knight G4 takes queen f8 with the point
being that if you move this bishop black
has the following tactical SE
uh wait wait wait wait wait a second
yeah
wait what what was I
thinking oh if you play the move Bishop
E1 black has the following tactical
sequence you know because I assume my
opponent would play poorly like a good
chess player Queen H6 yeah Queen H6 and
if King King
D1 yeah Knight E3 winning a queen so
that means that white would have to play
the move um Bishop to G3 but presumably
after Queen H6 black has some kind of
Advantage too um I decided against this
because I thought uh well what I did was
better I took on G5 and play Knight G4
the bishop is attacked so he moved
it okay what do you want to do with
black
yeah so um sometimes it's hard to
evaluate these queen versus two Rook
positions but this this one is
particularly good particularly good for
black takes takes takes on H1 what is
your
threat
for
yeah that would be that would be good
but you have something that like ends
the game if you could move again like
let's say white plays like I don't know
A3 now black wins
immediately somebody said
okay that move is just funny I don't
want to say it
but good job twitch
chat I don't necessarily understand your
moves but I do appreciate
them and if I move my
queen Checkmate yeah which is also nice
I think so you can't move move your
queen so you lose your queen for a
bishop right so Bishop A4 is a pretty
big deal my opponent played Knight C1
twitch chat was screaming Bishop A4 and
then they started screaming Knight A4
not sure what Knight A4 does not a ton
if anything it makes your position worse
um okay my opponent play Knight C1 what
would you guys like to
do
all right
somebody the same bishop move is is good
but you actually have something stronger
here Rook a f8 so you have a ton of like
winning moves here um I decided to play
like the cleanest human solution in my
opinion Rook af8 I think is actually the
computer suggestion I didn't do that um
the reason why the computer wants to do
that is it just wants to well or maybe
it it yeah it wants to go like Rook G1
and eventually BR his rook in the game
that's not what I did I just won the
game like immediately because I like
winning material I saw a way to win
material so that's what I
did I figured this Rook instead of going
to f8 should go
there somebody said Rook f8 followed by
Rook H2 which is incorrect because
that's how you lose chess
games don't do
that yeah you can you can win material
here Rook G1 that is correct so we
attack the bishop on on
G3 I thought if my opponent goes to E1
which he didn't if he goes to H4 this
compounds the problem I was going to go
Rook h8 anyway you go to E1 I play Rook
to H1 all of your things are on that
rank so I
win good game Bishop E1 is the same just
you play some move in between you can't
stop me from going Rook H1 so probably I
win the game here
too by probably I mean I would win
against anybody in the world
blindfolded so instead of that my
opponent played Knight
E2 which now you'll say the right
move oh me Bishop yeah Bishop Bishop A4
right so if you move the queen again as
Rook D1 Checkmate and my opponent took
on G1 I took on C2 um he played King C2
now granted um we did play some more
moves after this um I don't think it's
like super relevant to go over the game
anymore um black is up in exchange and
probably has compensation with being up
the exchange I play Knight E3 in the
game because I wanted to force this King
to B3
um yeah I played and then Rook f8 just
to cut activity uh maybe I'll go I'll go
through it like kind of fast um really
nah whatever so my opponent resigned in
like three moves or like four moves so
it doesn't like particularly matter um I
achieved this winning position um after
winning his Queen on C2 um so that was
more or less the game let's go back
through it now that we've we've seen it
um and sort of like recap what happened
right so I played this like very KY test
uh you know um aggressive line where you
aim to get like a bunch of imbalance as
early as black the reason why I did this
is because um I like playing for for the
win with both colors my opponent's rated
a 2197 you're not be you know in my
opinion it's really hard to beat this
like kind of player if you just play
like straight like straight Mainline
Theory they kind of know what's going on
so they get to play you know their their
systems and it's harder to beat that um
than if you force them to start playing
by themselves and plus there's a bunch
of imbalances and when there are
imbalances both players are more likely
to make a mistake the downside of
playing this way is I'm going to I'm
going to lose more chess games that's
just something I've accepted people are
going to upset me more often than maybe
they should at my rating level
um because I play provocative openings
like this but the upside is potentially
I'm going to win more tournaments
because I'm going to win more games
that's that's the upside so Bishop C3
this violates the opening principles but
has a very concrete positional purpose
and the reason why this principle exists
is because you're in general when you
move the same piece twice you're wasting
a bunch of time that's not as relevant
in the style of position because it's
closed right that's the that's the
overall point um I didn't mention this
at the time D takes E6 which attempts to
open the position is also an interesting
move and my friend gunar Anderson um
actually played this at us Masters maybe
this year or La no last year and um he
played the move F takes E6 and got a
really bad position remember Bishop
takes E6 and then you actually play for
a development Advantage so we like
switch styles of play um which is
another tough thing about the system it
sort of forces um if your opponent plays
like one way or another way you're going
to have to change your whole approach to
the opening
but this is the way that you play with
black if you want to get some
compensation um okay so after Pawn E5 my
opponent Play Bishop D3 and proceeded
with a natural development scheme Bishop
G5 is a bad move because I wanted to
play F6 anyway so essentially you are
moving the same piece twice you are
wasting time this it doesn't look like
white violated the opening principles
and black did uh didn't but that's
actually what happened because the
reasoning black was was probably going
to play all these moves anyway and
Bishop to E3 Bishop G5 E3 is just very
clearly a waste of time now it's my move
and he's going to have to react to what
it is that I'm doing I'm playing Knight
H6 King d8 again um it looks like this
is violating the opening principles
because you don't want to move your
major pieces out uh too early but the
reason why you don't want to do that
generally is your opponent is going to
play a bunch of moves attacking your
major pieces which wastes time King d8
doesn't waste time I want to put the K
on C7 because my king on C7 is going to
be very safe so that's what happened
Knight E2 King C7 I brought my King to
safety again you're like well castling
is an opening principle castling on the
king site is suicide I castle that
direction my opponent's going to blast
open the king side he's going to
Checkmate me so I decided to put my king
on the side of the board where he was
the safest because I understand the
principal behind you know behind the
fundamental opening principles right I
understand why the opening principles
exist so I can break them right
hopefully um now you guys do too it is
okay to break the opening principles you
just have to have
you know very sound and good logic and
you know like hopefully calculate well
or know
something just have to meet all that
criteria then you're allowed to break
the opening principles King D2 Knight D7
and this move Pawn to G4 didn't seem
like a big deal at the time this is
White's um big mistake of the game as
soon as you play Pawn to G4 black has
this break Pawn F5 in all of the
subsequent positions where I can open
the position my King's in the center
your King's in the center and you're
like well surely it must be the same but
I have the ability to open the center
and you do not that's what's changed
with the structure which means that
um uh I I can decide if it's favorable
for me to open the center and then I
will and I'll Crush you or I don't
because it's bad for me and then I just
don't open the
center um oops if White had decided to
not play the move Pawn to
G4 and just like played some move it
would be a lot tougher to to proceed in
like a normal probably the move Pawn uh
Pawn to A4 is natural I would play a
move like Pawn A5 to stop him from going
A5 um I would yeah SSP Rook A6 Knight B6
would be a normal development scheme and
then both sides have like a very
playable position I would choose black
because I think it's easier to play
Black in this style of position because
the C4 Pawn is kind of funny but
nobody's going to claim that white is
like worse White's probably not worse um
it's just a very tense interesting
position where there's a bunch of
struggle but my opponent is Master Level
player who's never seen this type of
position before and as a result he
played this move G4 which is just a
positional mistake had he seen this
before he probably wouldn't have played
G4 because he would understand that this
F5 um this F5 break is a big deal and he
needs this Pawn on F3 to be able to
defend his Center so that is why he lost
the game and uh you're like well that
game looked kind of easy it's because I
kind of understood the plans of this
opening and my opponent wasn't super
familiar and it's not like my opponent
is like a badge play or anything it's
just that he wasn't familiar with this
particular style um of opening uh do you
guys have any questions before we go
ahead and call it a
day no cool all right well thank you
guys for showing up to my class for the
road to 2000 hopefully now you too will
break the opening principles like I do
all right have a good one bye thank
[Music]
you
oh